you
it's been a while since i streamed in
eastern bold arena but this is what we
have here a one-hour bullet tournament
our of one minute chests Grunfeld are
not no all right this is a very popular
setup
I like to go for this and I'll keep the
tension
they're playing d5 no I'll let me get
into this right now
prepping this move so castles and it's
really weakening
shouldn't that be a pain I'm going to
insist on getting there um I'll babysit
on the night that was a big blunder I'm
on the rook as well yeah and here's the
other thing on this I have Knight d5
something better I got the exchange at
least and oh no I don't want it they'll
take with the knight and beyond my rook
so let me start with start with this 20
seconds 20 seconds all right let's get
him playing my life square Bishop needs
to play as well
nights going there I have to break stuff
up
yeah it's a really strong night
there I take here it's a clean okay
that's a really tough pin to get out of
a pile up on I only have ten seconds
about whoa what's the story with that
and the bishop I'll just sack
okay
you
I'm just take there
you
Oh No gotta get that off
ha man I played some crazy house and I I
had that uh you know what I'm trying to
say no man always promote to Queen okay
let's get back in there
that cost me that cost me ah precious
tenths of a second okay I was I was
playing really slow though just in
general with that I'm doing the same
setup basically with the black side now
but I think it's good if you could get
this light square bishop playing at
least in this system all right
I'm trying for c4 I'll hold this tension
here I still want c4 I want to break
down the structure he's going to be a
beast let's still do it now they're in a
pin they're out of it I'm on here though
I'll follow up with this now d4 Queen b6
challenging the rook Ritchie a - I'll
leave that there I could recapture okay
back up if they don't take my bishop
we're ready now we target b2 and it's
tough to defend that move all right
let's put some more pressure on c3 I
could have played Bishop to d3 let's try
this now I'm getting b2 now okay I have
a knight here is blocking the back rank
I could do this it's important I have
night to f8 there and now I guess I'll
just push into a victory lane how does
he get stopped he's way out of play
and I think I could just keep pushing
look on b2 and then rook to d1
I just want to rip trade now let's get a
flight square right now I want to flight
square down on time again can I take
advantage of this pin
let's just block playing extra slow
and now we have to
go into a pan or something like that
right
nights are connected
get out of that pen finally huh
yeah I have to pick up the pace I
definitely have to pick up the pace okay
I got the W that's nice but I don't like
how I'm converting them getting I got a
good position there but yeah hi
let's get back on the horse the horsey
okay I guess Queen to b6 I have the
bishop hair and a bit of a strength and
center now they might struggle some they
will likely struggle some that guy's a
killer no castling clean a four are they
castling how are they castling all right
I'm going to stop threatening mate now
OOP and then see the mate the Duke went
down
we're walkin is in first with nine
this is one there you have to pace
yourself an hour of 1-minute chesses
it's a bit much I've done a hour of
hyper bullet but I don't know that I've
ever done that all recording or
streaming I'm getting berserk love it
okay Kings Indian okay he's no longer
around to stop that so okay that's a
super thorn where's the mate
I have a super thorn oh they just killed
it on Bishop
that's a fork I don't want the rook I
want this guy I'm up a rope okay this is
this is big trouble
for Team black really big trouble
let's kick him away alrighty I'll take
him got a block with the rook take care
could do a look up and over soon so many
so many different moves now just
clearing the way for c4 now I'm getting
fancy
threatening this and then that a deadly
combo watch out for the do this the dis
that combo all right I'm at nine
70 players are in this one
long way to go whoo okay
trackpad on board let's see we get
against trackpad let's throw a Sicilian
maybe we go fishing
I like Queen c7 it's flexible a three a
four so there's some time loss with that
now let's put the bishop here
can I
that guy down I think I can hang on it's
not reason to take him just yet
to take with the pawned by the way
otherwise I get the Queen let's take
care first now here they got to take
with the pawn and then how about we put
the bishop here otherwise there might be
some fancy stuff against my queen and
bishop this is a home he five is a home
for any of my pieces like a castle
safely he spent a lot of time there
let's just get some trades in on the
bishop twice if he moves I jump in I
know I have this covered so probably
have to get rid of that Knight he's just
too good could take on b2 or just play
this Knight takes pawn and I have that
with check again so just castle over
protect f7
this is really close and then I can
follow up with beef or I could just do
it I could do it still I think like this
capture also doing this with an eye on
the clock yeah I could do anything now
and I have any time another now they're
flying they'll never suspect that what
why are you playing like a machine your
time is supposed to just
you know the time burner was that was a
time burning tactic but no time was
being burned gotta rethink tough they
started kicking into higher gear all
right we got the Duke again
let's throw c4 at the Duke
alrighty so 2 to 1 in the center what
can we do with this let's not drop D for
D for first
alright so smooth development they
wasted some time there's no cost yeah I
experienced no cost they didn't make me
struggle to get the C pawn back there C
pun so take here i strengthen my center
and now I'm going to reposition and
shoot for a 5 ok now this is a big
problem we got
two bishops adjacent diagonals killers
so how can we bring more pieces into the
attack probably this right now let's
throw a jab at the Queen first I just
want to take the night out even though
my my dark square bishop is pretty
dangerous I I'm up material so still
look at these squares he's having a
tough day cop behind his pawns
nf6 now 5 gives me an e 5 squared to
work with on g6 now now they'll have any
time where is the mate right there
back to tournament I got 17 Christopher
Walken is on a tear
it's got 22 couple berserks in there
okay
see
87 are now in this what up yo dog I got
to play faster against this guy alright
they're not making me struggle to get
that pond back now there should be five
checks or anything so okay that move let
me treat there I want to get my knight
on d5 are they going to stop that now a3
may have been a move I'll wait for them
to kick me okay and now they're going to
line up some uh some stuff here I have
enough defense um I'll do this yeah I
know you could do that but I thought
that this would be okay actually so I
did this rook move sneaky King
say fizzy though not too safe that
Bishop before Oh what hobb dead I am
dead
they just pinpointed my queen and I said
I don't care about that
ah man I have the rook - ah man I think
I have to kick him away
it's not good ah what's having fun not
me
I've been shuffle big trouble uncle
uncle I'm in big trouble
yeah I can't be like any time right
now's a good time that was that wasn't a
good idea
ah man so queen a7 yeah I get the e7
square for my king but they have Bishop
efore you got it you got to play better
chest you got the top guy with 27 you're
down here at 17 how much time's left 44
minutes plenty I'm just setting setting
myself up for a comeback am i dropping a
queen paranoid now every move I have to
question is my queen safe okay the Queen
safe
No let's trade I let's not down that guy
let's go here don't touch this pawn
about to see five square let's get my
clean out of the line of fire
you should be pretty pesky I'll go here
stay central now will key in on this
week's square I don't know I pass that's
a pass a three not quite sure what to do
I could shoot for e4 let's do it take
with the rook yes because we like this
we're going to get some trades more
trades let's shoot him away how about we
play up four
Oh sacking giving up the exchange in
order to acquire a lethal Bishop
a lethal Bishop okay it's pretty
dangerous I'll take the bishop oh yeah
let's just take my king is naked he
doesn't like that I don't know let's
just stay defended nine seconds
just drop your beep on who needs them
right
just drop every pun
clean exchange got anything sneaky
you
oh my god what barely ah man
these are not good games okay turkey
chili
ah b3 when in doubt played b3 the
answers to all your problems
display b3 it's going to be okay I don't
know this is such a fun game you're
missing out if you know if you're
watching right now and you don't know
how to play chess you're just missing
out it's a matter with you
don't be intimidated come on I know a
lot of you out there intimidated I know
how to play checkers but you mean
there's all these different pieces and
they move in different ways I can't do
that yes you can it's a good game how
much fun this nice having you getting
kicked around your opponent's advancing
forcing you backwards what a blast
all right this is where the action is
is where it is the rooks are ready to
rumble
here we go it'll take a little bit
concern on my dark squares
I'll give the exchange I will definitely
give the exchange I get in that pawn
back and I watch out for that he's he's
still kind of short on squares though
throw a quick jab at him king h2 where's
he gone g3
anything fancy here I'm giving up the
Queen yeah alright so now I'm up
material
I got coordination alright they were way
down on time
like I have been for many of the games
so far okay
okay when we tell a 45 and mirrors is
the opponent it is very rare for me to
meet efore with e5 okay so this is not a
good idea because of this break okay so
I could win some material now I'll keep
this tension I give the rooks in play so
I could have maybe played rook b8 and
then have this threat mm I guess right
here key and on h2 there without a key
defender on the Kings side so maybe we
drift over here and start going caveman
like this is already deadly okay how do
I want to do it I guess we're gonna just
hit him with a fork oh you dummy just uh
I should have just captured here at the
bishop all right
just move fast I'll give a check and
play here yeah I should
Bishop takes a charge forgetting I had
another attacker there
tonight's a sidelined I could take there
alright let's just get everybody playing
invite all your pieces to the party
where is yes are cerumen he says that
okay invite all your pieces to the party
that's what I'm doing so fork keep the
king cut off pick up this guy and that
guy okay they resigned back to terminal
where we stand here I got 25
what up your dog has been on a tear the
drawed okay we got trackpad again
this the second or third time in this
tournament now all right
simple simpleton jeff's simple and
effective looking for something playable
not bad not bad
let's try queenside how long can my
opponent hold off on this keeping this
tension we're going to find out
it's more of an inconvenience for the
black queen than it is my h2 pond to be
defending the bishops can win this guy
maybe now they they take on their twice
I have the rook playing now and I guess
we'll take and now I'm insisting on
crashing through here trying to weasel
in now let's just go for a clean trade I
am up a pond I may be able to continue
some attack doubling up in g4
okay still g4 oh look I have to be a
little bit careful my back rank I got
this square covered yeah I'm attacking
with all my pieces let's try this okay I
just want to trade a little bit
this pond scares me some so
let's go here I need to get my king like
on g3 okay at this
care if I drop upon I just want my king
and rook active
pressure on b3 they're also laid down on
the clock now and I could just scoop up
everything all right back to tournament
yeah that's one of the things you get
with bishop backing up the bishop on the
g3 at some point it becomes
uncomfortable for your opponent to keep
their queen around - I didn't mean to do
that
I wasted so much time there yeah this is
I'm going to drop this pawn normally I'd
have my clean on a5 okay this is a this
is a pain now yeah trouble trouble
trouble trouble okay
now I'm down another pond I don't know
let's try to keep the night around feel
like I'm going to need them yeah not
cool man not cool at all yeah big
trouble
trouble
this is extra scary extra scary I don't
know what to do need a flight square
rook there watch out for this
stop doing that man stop doing that
let's check ok I get a pawn back I get a
second one need to keep two rooks on
have to somehow be a time burning
machine how do we pull this off
can you pull this off
okay
you
coley cow oh that was a really bad Mouse
lip that's a time sensitive variation
okay and there's no time to breathe okay
he this guy slipped up this is the pack
leader he slipped up now we have the
same thing in okay well I'm going to
take a different approach with my C pawn
ok g5 is the only thing I have to be on
the lookout for their Queen can't feel
too comfortable being opposite my rook
and yeah let's go here I guess hmm guess
I'm dropping upon I'm making a making a
habit out of this let's let's stop on
grabbing
yeah position right
let's go here wow this is dangerous
how's this move what's what's happening
here my Knights hitting a lot of stuff a
lot of stuff the Queen and Bishop are
now hit could take that yeah I go here
this night is really really dangerous
defend be to drop a two
drop my night yikes
got my queen
don't see it man don't see it up inside
oh man this is the second time I drop my
queen against this player what is
happening
am i dropping my queen like this
you
they didn't take my rook why are they
not taking my rook
what deserve lose I deserve I go
negative negative points with that one
oh yeah ah man Zabu er okay we're at the
about the halfway point I better kick it
in see I still have a chance somehow I'm
not performing well but I still have 33
top is at 42
all right you got a regroup you had a
stop drop in pieces
let's see alright we're gonna we're
going to go on the offensive now we're
going to try some aggressive chess from
now on the rest of this tournament we'll
try some aggressive stuff be taking
suggestions looking at the chat not
really enough time left [ __ ] to look
at the chat it's too much okay we're
going to go after the king's head
where is the king's head alright that's
helpful get that Bishop I'll take the
Queen they resign back determine look at
that I found one move
okay we got 35 how do we play aggressive
c5 no matter what we go fishing a little
bit start looking at the the cheap
little tactics each to stuff they're
gone clean side
they're already sensing fishing pole
going kingside let's throw the H pond
let's keep going he's a dangerous man
that H Vaughn man a dangerous man are
you covering up f4
oh you realize that night could be
sniped okay come on f4 twice
[Music]
I want to do this is kind of scary night
getting here yeah yeah you're getting my
bishop aren't you yes you are nice
tactic man nice tactic well done well
done
I gotta get rid of that night he's not
going anywhere
maybe f5 is where I want to be still
hoping for an attack by the way not
giving up on that I'm on g2 I have a
fork
I put your knight here man you only had
that for seven moves only seven moves
you had that move
what's the clock situation where we got
that night is so dangerous
be very careful I'm on the a3 pawn I
guess we'll take like this
Queen here I could take on a three let's
give a Czech guard this diagonal dick
like that and then take drop your queen
just get the cleans off that way oh my
god my Queens dead oh oh man
that's all I could do is time burners
oh my god
ah oh man
ah had chiii so many times
oh man with Sue's man I was on f5 I had
night 2g threes for so many moves ah if
I don't get my act together this guy is
going to smack me around again best buy
test alright let's try a scotch I feel
like I need to win out
I need to win out from here on out okay
let's see what we get here no I want to
take like that how long can we hold off
on this tension I'm just going to take
now yeah having the a2 phone I could
have grabbed the a to pawn it could be
extra careful of my dark squares my
light squares okay yeah this is no good
oh man I'm getting hammered down the
exchange this is too easy this is way
too easy I'm making life way too easy
for my opponents ah way too easy
ah man
I don't know I don't know how to correct
it gotta cover this square I am in big
trouble I don't know how to improve okay
I found a way to improve bishops going
to give a check yeah I got nothing
how to reposition my knight I can't even
land a check
I want to land a check but I can't oh
boy
I should resign oh man
52:41 3630 524 left
hmm all right here we go
the nimzo-indian ah man
c5 96 d5 I don't know what's going on
not good
94 I could play g5 but they'll probably
have a sack so not at least I could drop
back to break the pin Wow
I am missing everything he answered I
don't have any answers oh I don't know I
just don't know I could have captured
the night and then played Queen here
let's try this can I get a win is it
close to win the bishop be able to block
an f1 let's try that out let's insert
this check out of lock with the Queenie
okay I should be able to get this one
we'll see though I have zero confidence
at this point it just don't know you
could take that rook holy cow watch I'm
going to get back rank mated they took
away my flight square I'm not at the
point where able to take that and then
fall for this yet yet swayed though put
your queen in a dangerous spot though I
apologize I'm sorry I'm sorry you're
having to witness this terrible
where is Barclay I was ready to give a
check instead of taking the rook that's
where I'm at
not to be fancy just because I don't got
I'm not seeing it you know instead of
taking the rook directly let's hit it
with a fork first to show out from your
your fork tactics I'm going to take the
rook don't take the rook directly don't
take the RIP directly just be fancy be
stupid okay
come on now you could still somehow win
this right twenty two minutes left just
win oh that's all you got to do
it's going to be okay here we go
just went out and it's going to be okay
here we go
let's let's throw one move punches okay
and can we get to c5 I was really close
to getting c5 still want that H pawn I
had a good position I could take like
this my queen is there to defend just in
the nick of time
all right this should be pretty
dangerous now oh I think I have to do
this it's getting too scary and I can't
even take that still
oh man if I don't if I don't continue to
laugh man you know what's happening if
you don't laugh you're going to cry
that's where I'm at Oh down a full ruck
anyone if anyone's keeping track down a
full rook
yeah no man I cannot afford trades can't
do it they're in the think tank not sure
what that's doing dropping another phone
get the beep on all right it's scary
check I'm getting the night for free
come on man you could do it use some
time burning stuff he was pinned don't
take pin pieces ever
holy cow
those are the only kind of things I'm
going to get that's all you've got 60
okay
for where's this aggressive chest I said
I was going to play where is it throw
your pieces out quick welcome to many
ponds if we go queenside take them no
giving me that file for free huh I'll
take it let's try this get rid of that
key defender come on double up here
there let's try this sneak into h6
denied give me the a pond let's do this
I could have taken that man where's my
knife belong what about here let's try
this
King on b2 somebody can move my queen is
super active let's go night you got to
do something better your dummy on c3 see
pond is embarrassing you okay rook clean
trapped no quite but there's a pond come
on take free stuff take free stuff
where's the free stuff right here
GG six come on night drop the hammer
check
I could take here and just block I'm
getting this next I have a boatload of
pawns I love it
okay you could win this one pretty sure
you know how to win this one
all right let's go King there you go
have fun
no Stan lates now stalemates Nate back
determine okay I got a four fours are
hard to come by
62 45 43 I'm in third somehow
oh okay okay okay how many more games
can I get in nine
ah I don't know I don't have confidence
let's try this setup keep my Center keep
the center now they're trying a fishing
pole me trying fishing pole stuff let's
reinforce a five I want to jump in here
take me take on e5 yes now let's jump in
I got a passed pawn can I work with that
guy oh he's he's alive you're allowing
him to live huh I'll shoot this and shoe
this him shoot him away huh
let's take the light square bishop first
and I don't know let's do that
I don't want to open up the G file
that's why I didn't take here nice and a
pen you know I'm just going to hold my
ground with my EEP on
feel like there should have been a
better kill earlier the King's running
now he's a scaredy cat no I don't want
raids how about my queen on f4 let's try
that
I'll take major P sending the king is
without a home I could take here now oh
my god
the one moved up they had they had made
on g2 yep that's where we're at
tiny burning time time burning time
seven seconds
time burning time this is fantastic
technique on the clean oh they give it
back oh okay
of stuff back to tournament don't look
at that game ever again
um and ugliness that pollen was poison
I took them though
here we go with d5 with tempo more Tempe
or Tempe let's let's try this build a
center and then push your opponent
around strengthen your center now he
gave him a boot and this Knight does a
little dance how about he goes further
no no c5 for you trade
Bishop's I can work around a night here
I'm going for the kill
setting it up right now night h4 take
what the pond on h2 whoo this is a
killer diagonals open now be careful
take upon making one threat Oh whoo
sneaky where's the fancy moves can I
just push my H pon mo huh
and I'll take him oh this bishop could
come over here
now let's push my age fun clean us to
stay defending here okay let's keep
pushing
you have a check and I could take on f
to clean trade now - cleans around this
square
no time I have zero confidence right now
got 51
can I get second I don't think I'm
catching him six more games possible I
need to get paired up and win no that's
the problem I have to do the impossible
no I can't beat that guy I'm just not in
not in any form I was going to say good
form just not in any form I don't know
what you call it oh okay yeah he goes
fishing when he's having a tough time at
the office that's what he does alright
I'll pitch up on
I have an open line and this
LightSquared bishop so you turn to a
beast let's not take here how to watch
out for Knight to d5 stuff
oh let's castle f5 let's do it
killer or is it
I could take here and am I really good
having an attack I don't think so sure
I'm spending a lot of time okay I gave
up no attack no attack
yeah one rook will be traded I don't
know how I get active
okay need to create
type of imbalance okay here's the
imbalance outside past pawn keep going
with them
I'll keep going I'm going to guard
laterally you know I think I need to run
it like this my Kings they're just in
time oh they had yeah they go to the
corner I'm keeping my rook there
the check now their downtime is hoping
to clean what's check
I got 55 I'm in second okay Christopher
Walken
all right I guess we'll turn into a
Sicilian let's try for deform okay this
should be a problem because now I'm
going to get a valuable tempo against
the Queen once my wreck is on c1 let's
see at the h-file I'm still anticipating
a valuable temple against the Queen she
is on a completely open file
there's the temp thought I was talking
about that move Oh
Knight here and then queen h5 I'm still
gonna do this she's too strong here
yeah going for mates on each to clean
trade and then the night has to find a
new home I should be able to get the
pond back they take here to prove the
king my king on d4 oh they thought the
roofs are connected they thought the
bishop was moved well he drew he's got
71 I have 59 I'm 12 back with nine
minutes to go hmm maybe maybe sure use a
win like within I'm just a minute and a
half type games so much for playing
aggressive right it's not my nature okay
I got the bishops all right let's try
Queen side I'm going to give me the true
bishop pair my queen needs to get out of
the way okay
once I wanted to open up a little bit
and now I could win this pond with okay
hmm and do it like this yeah
that move I really afraid of that move
take him out and then go here take with
the pond and then target g7 I don't
think there's anything fancy here Bishop
to b3 now I'm going to give up the sea
to pond it's just a check how they
stopping mate nearly pre-move that
that's made back to tournament like I
was flying I have ten back 73 63 we both
have fire three games left
okay I guess we'll try a Sicilian
let's see
ha6 first and okay so it's a lock Center
I got to get my LightSquared Bishop
doing something productive I don't know
that I want to castle so soon I'm okay
with it
my LightSquared bishop
okay if the knight moves Bishop to b5
just as I said that I don't have to take
that ruck just yet he's not going
anywhere
so I'll treat this as if it's like a pin
I just want some trades get rid of him
so that my rook can finally play he's
playing now and that's a one pawn any
fancy tactics here I have pressure on
the knight
so let's put him on a good square and
now get my queen well let's just take
him on the b-pawn
you
scary let's try this and then get up the
h1 square let's give a check check here
and that's me hmm okay didn't calculate
that I'm six back okay so he drew again
or something six back he's uh in a game
right now it's doable
okay this is game going to finish up and
we're going to get played are paired up
we can get played
here we go I have to win this one
I gotta stay focused how can I not
blunder my queen okay don't uh yeah it's
no wonder my job a queen oh man okay
just maybe we just don't allow that to
happen anymore we do that to stop the
Queen from getting into h7 for sure
that's the plan we're going to try it
give you some exchanges let's throw
let's throw that in there hmm
how about this I'm getting some stuff
hell for that again
okay I should be getting some material
though yeah that move let's take the
tricky night and then extend my bishop
let's take here I'll hide behind that
pond and yeah very interesting in
balance I think I'm better here I could
give a check with the bishop let's just
stay coordinated maybe I do want to take
this pawn now can I write to g8 try it
those bishops are killers No
there are killers
that's a pin how do you get out of that
Lu let's mate even that's not but many
next who what a interesting imbalance
still six back three minutes to go I
need to win these next two um yeah
alright let's see if I could get this
one yeah okay
he may get something against h7
I'm Triforce e5 note and allowing that
isn't going to be a quick one
I'll keep my knight around hmm look here
I have Bishop to f5 pile up on the
pinned bishop by night doing something
oh and down a piece
the pen I'm in a pickle I'm done was it
meant to be okay
he has tough being down a full-piece
it's kind of tough being down a
full-piece rook here would have won the
piece back
yikes yeah I should have played Rick to
c5 oh well and they're just going to
trade I'm in check
there wasn't even any there wasn't going
to be a way to catch him anyhow
[Music]
yeah they're just
taking stuff now okay okay
uncle uncle let's try one last one he's
ate up I guess I'm gonna hold on to
second I should be thankful for that
fifty seconds left let's see what we get
more game or not 167 in here alright the
last one it will not count for the
tournament more yeah it's just not going
to come here we go hmm
efore
a simple simpleton knight on d5 should
be pretty good soon let's just protect
efore castle now
I guess I could have jumped in first but
I had some concern of this
key in on c7 now I'm definitely getting
there waiting upon at least I think I
should just get him right out of there
find some safe ground okay I'll take
another pond and double up on the D file
let's just roll out c4 my nights are
more central than theirs I'm okay with
the Queen exchange of two pawns and this
guy is not so healthy 93 I could try for
Queen here and maybe Knight f6 one day
or flight square and pawn on h6 oh it's
a free queen and they're going to resign
I imagine yes back to tournament second
place
what up yo dog first in at 79 Congrats
71-57 54-49 167 in all let's see all the
pages who has a rough one did not feel
confident in many of the games okay
17 pages I need a granola bar maybe
that's the thing maybe you just need a
granola bar that's all
little carbs for your chest okay
167 in all to the 166 of you the games
all okay
you